wine spectator magazine just released
its winners in their annual restaurant
awards and we told you that 59 local
spots made the list and five received
top honors named grand award winners
joining us this morning to talk about it
cassia shifter wine spectators associate
tasting coordinator and the director of
the restaurant awards
cassia thanks for being here this
morning talk to me about the las vegas
restaurants that made the list and what
made these particular spots stand out
yeah of course thank you for having me
good morning
there are as you said 59 winners in las
vegas and five of them are our grand
award winners
and we have three levels of award the
award of excellence best of award of
excellence and the grand award which is
our top highest honor only 97
restaurants in the world currently hold
it
um what we look for there and how they
caught our eye is you know generally a
wine list that has over a thousand
selection which is a huge a huge number
a lot of diversity both in terms of
where the wines are from uh vintages
producer pretty much everything
has to have great presentation
all the correct information um
and just sort of go above and beyond the
extra mile in terms of service educating
their staff who can then educate the
diners
because our goal is just to make sure
everyone feels comfortable going to a
restaurant ordering a bottle of wine
that they love ah and that's so
important too you know obviously the
sommeliers help with that so i'm
guessing when you're going through these
wines are you looking at the food items
that are served as well and to see if
there's some kind of connection or good
pairing options
absolutely
it's definitely not the end all and be
all but you know if you're going to a
sushi restaurant and they only have
cabernet sauvignon on the menu i feel
like that's a little bit limiting and in
the same vein you know a steakhouse that
only has white wine might be a little
odd pairing um
but for the most part
you know as long as it's a really good
wine less and it does fit the vibe of
the restaurant the theme of the
restaurant the cuisine
you know that's the more important part
of
the awards are you know having that put
together wine list with great selections
well vegas knows how to do it i'll tell
you that really quick before i let you
go for the average wine consumer
you know is it about the vineyard and
the location or is it about the brand
what should we be looking looking at
honestly it's really about personal
preference and you know people ask me
all the time how do i learn about wine
how do i get to know
all the important things
i i really think the most important
thing is just knowing what you like
knowing
you know what you don't like
knowing what's in your correct price
range and being able to order that
confidently is more important to me i
think than
you know knowing you know the grand cru
vineyards of burgundy and such
all good information cassia thank you so
much for joining us this morning as we
get ready for our
wine tasting weekend i suppose
have a great day thank you